[Música]
esta es la segunda vez que tengo la
oportunidad y el gusto de compartir
algunas ideas algunas reflexiones
algunas historias en un espacio télex la
primera vez fue hace aproximadamente
seis años y el evento fue en hermosillo
yo vivo en monterrey por lo que tuve que
pedir permiso un día de vacaciones para
ausentarme de mi trabajo y pues
evidentemente yo estaba súper emocionada
de poder participar en un evento como
este y cuando le compartí a mí entonces
jefe la razón por la cual me ausentaría
pues lo que él me contestó me sorprendió
un montón cuando le platiqué que me
habían invitado a participar en un
evento text me dijo y tú como porque tú
que tienes que decir en un evento como
ese
y la verdad pues yo me quedé pasmada no
sé si alguna vez te ha pasado puedas
recordar alguna experiencia en la que te
hayas sentido
invalidado no escuchado no respetado no
respetada en la que pareciera que en tu
espacio de trabajo solo valiera por las
tareas que desempeñan y no pudieran ver
más allá del potencial que tienes y de
lo que puedes aportar a la organización
justamente así fue como yo me sentí y
después de procesar la experiencia de
consultarlo con la almohada pues decidí
renunciar y entonces inicie un camino de
emprendimiento con un propósito el de
transformar a las organizaciones y
ayudar a que pasen de ser estos espacios
donde pareciera que utilizamos a las
personas como un recurso para generar
dinero a maximizar las utilidades de
unos cuantos hacer espacios donde todos
y todas tengamos la oportunidad de
desarrollarnos y
encontrar o generar juntos bienestar y
riqueza compartida
y bueno no me dejarán mentir que hoy
estamos viviendo un momento histórico y
no solamente por el tema del cob y de la
pandemia sino que hay muchos autores y
estrategas de negocios que hablan que
estamos justo transitando hacia una
quinta revolución industrial o
empresarial
es una nueva era donde pues sin duda los
avances tecnológicos nos han llevado a
que hoy existan máquinas que puedan
hacer mucho mejor muchas tareas que las
personas solían hacer e incluso superar
nuestra inteligencia es una era donde
las personas tendremos que aprender a
colaborar ya trabajar juntos mucho mejor
y además a colaborar con las máquinas en
este contexto la mayor riqueza y eso que
nosotros podemos aportar a las
organizaciones será justamente eso que
las máquinas no han podido replicar aún
por ejemplo habilidades como la empatía
intuición como la creatividad pues serán
esos diferenciadores que nos permitirán
pues seguir siendo valiosos y relevantes
en las organizaciones otra
característica de esta nueva era de los
negocios pues es que hoy estamos frente
a la responsabilidad de tener que
resolver muchos de los efectos negativos
que generaron las revoluciones
anteriores atender los efectos del
cambio climático o la escasez de la
escasez de recursos y las desigualdades
sociales pues son algunas de las cosas
que hoy las organizaciones tendrán que
asumir como parte de su responsabilidad
y pues en este contexto sin duda estamos
transitando hacia un nuevo juego
económico hacia nuevas reglas de cómo
debiéramos hacer negocios y una de esas
nuevas reglas que ha cobrado mucha
relevancia en los últimos años justo es
el tema de la diversidad de inclusión
muy probablemente lo habrán escuchado
pero no necesariamente tenemos claro a
qué se refieren estos dos términos y son
sinónimos
cuando hablamos de diversidad nos
referimos a esto que existe y sucede
sólo porque haya dos o más personas en
un mismo espacio a partir de reconocer
que todos somos distintos que todas
somos diferentes
inclusión es todo aquello que se refiere
a las acciones intencionadas por crear
las condiciones para que todos y todas
podamos tener la oportunidad de
sentirnos parte de sentirnos incluidos y
de tener este sentido de pertenencia
dice la directora de diversidad e
inclusión de netflix que
diversidad es como que te inviten a la
fiesta e inclusión pues es que te saquen
a bailar y bueno esto sin duda hoy es un
tema súper relevante porque en este
contexto de tantos cambios de tanta
ambigüedad de tanta incertidumbre en el
que hoy estamos haciendo negocios la
diversidad y la inclusión se vuelven
ingredientes fundamentales para poder
generar o crear equipos fuertes
resilientes que tengan esta capacidad de
resolver múltiples problemáticas
darse a diferentes cambios de ser
innovadores
y
si esto es así y si volviendo a la
definición entendemos que todos los
equipos son diversos que nos estaría
faltando para de verdad asegurarnos de
que todos los equipos sean estos equipos
de ensueño que generan grandes
resultados que son innovadores creativos
y que pueden resolver cualquier problema
que se les enfrente observemos primero
el tema de la diversidad
hace algunos meses tuve la oportunidad
de facilitar un panel donde había
diferentes empresas compartiendo pues
sus mejores prácticas respecto a temas
de diversidad e inclusión y me
sorprendió mucho aprender sobre lo que
hace steel cage que es una organización
que tiene presencia en diferentes
ciudades del mundo ellos han
desarrollado una estrategia de
diversidad muy robusta donde uno de los
compromisos que tienen es trabajar por
asegurar que la diversidad del talento
en la organización en los equipos de
verdad represente la diversidad que
componen las comunidades de las que son
parte y esto es muy interesante porque
implica reconocer que cada comunidad es
diferente por supuesto que la diversidad
de la comunidad donde opera su planta en
monterrey que a lo mejor en nueva york'
o incluso la mejor dentro del mismo
méxico pero en tabasco es diferente y
entonces ellos parten de observar y
entender cómo están compuestas de estas
comunidades y especialmente identificar
cuáles son esos segmentos de la
población que sistémicamente encuentran
mayores obstáculos para encontrar
oportunidades de empleo y de desarrollo
y entonces ellos trabajar desde sus
estrategias de reclutamiento y de
desarrollo para minimizar esas barreras
de entrada y entonces que de verdad sus
equipos representen esa diversidad que
hay en esas comunidades imágenes de esto
es poder llevar el tema de la diversidad
a un siguiente nivel
otro elemento que también es relevante
cuando hablamos de diversidad es
identificar dónde está la diversidad
dentro de la organización porque
varias organizaciones con las que
trabajamos nos dicen o nosotros estamos
comprometidos con la paridad de género y
aquí los porcentajes de hombres y
mujeres claro que somos incluyentes pero
si observamos dónde está ubicada la
diversidad dentro de la organización nos
damos cuenta que en los consejos de
administración o en los consejos
directivos sigue siendo el mismo perfil
de personas ahí no son diversos y
entonces esto lo que genera es que todo
el potencial de beneficios que la
diversidad podría atraer a la
organización pues se dispersa de hecho
unos investigadores pudieron demostrar a
partir de un estudio de diversas
organizaciones en eeuu que el incremento
del 1 por ciento en la diversidad racial
en los equipos directivos
genera al menos un incremento de 730
dólares en la productividad por persona
una organización imagínense si hacemos
la sumatoria cómo podemos monetizar esos
beneficios y con esto en mente yo
quisiera invitarte a observar qué tan
diverso en realidad es tu equipo hoy que
tan diversa es tu organización donde
estamos ubicando y generando estas
oportunidades o esa riqueza de la
diversidad dentro de la organización
en los años que tengo trabajando justo
en el cruce entre el desarrollo
organizacional y el desarrollo
sostenible he aprendido y descubierto
que las organizaciones y las empresas
son como estas micro sociedades que
pueden ser por un lado la réplica de lo
que se vive en una sociedad en una
comunidad con sus luces y sombras' o
pueden ser también estos espacios que
sirvan de laboratorio para
experimentar y crear
dinámicas diferentes relaciones
distintas que luego podamos replicar en
la sociedad en las comunidades y empezar
a transformar esas realidades y
aprendí esto a partir de una experiencia
que tuve hace algunos años justo
estábamos dando una capacitación a un
equipo de ventas sobre temas de
y construcción de confianza con los
clientes empatía escucha activa y al
finalizar este taller uno de los
participantes compartió con todo el
grupo que se había dado cuenta a partir
de estas reflexiones que tenía años de
no poner en práctica la escucha activa
con sus hijos que se daba cuenta que
justo su equipo más importante en la
vida que era su esposa y su familia lo
tenía muy descuidado y se comprometió a
poner en práctica justo la empatía y
estas habilidades para fortalecer ese
equipo
imagínense el potencial que hay dentro
de una empresa para transformar poco a
poquito de esas realidades esos
contextos en los que viven las personas
que colaboran con nosotros
sin duda
hablar de diversidad e inclusión y
comprometernos a meterle más intención
es una gran oportunidad de robustecer la
dinámica de los equipos de generar mucho
mayor innovación mucha mayor agilidad en
consecuencia también poder alcanzar
mejores resultados y también poder
transformar esas comunidades y esas
realidades en las que operan nuestras
organizaciones si queremos aprovechar
todas estas oportunidades es importante
que nos demos a la tarea de crear los
contextos seguros para que todos y todas
no solamente podamos desempeñar nuestras
funciones o nuestras tareas sino crear
estos espacios donde todos y todas
podamos sentirnos parte y con la
oportunidad de compartir nuestras ideas
y explotar nuestra creatividad y está
tarea recae sobre todos aquellos y todas
aquellas que tienen la responsabilidad y
la oportunidad de liderar un equipo yo
te quiero compartir tres cosas tres
acciones concretas que tú puedes empezar
a hacer a partir de hoy para generar
justo estos espacios y de confianza
donde podamos capitalizar toda esa
riqueza que tiene la diversidad dentro
de tu equipo la primera es que te
comprometas a reconocer y conocer a las
personas que trabajan contigo más allá
de su rol más allá de la tarea que
desempeña y tres elementos que nos
pueden ayudar a abrir esa ventana para
ver más allá de lo evidente para conocer
a las personas con las que trabajamos es
poder hablar sobre las historias de vida
cómo es que llegamos a donde estamos hoy
no solamente en el contexto de lo
profesional sino cómo era nuestra
infancia cómo es nuestra familia cuáles
son aquellas anécdotas que nos marcaron
esas personas que han influido en
nosotros otro elemento para conocer
mejor a las personas con las que
convivimos y trabajamos es abrir
espacios para hablar sobre nuestros
sueños sobre aquello que anhelamos y un
tercer elemento es conocer cuáles son
las metas por las cuales estamos
trabajando no solamente en lo
profesional sino también en lo personal
esas metas
muy probablemente sean la gasolina o la
motivación por la cual estamos
comprometidos a dar el extra en el
trabajo
una segunda recomendación es también
comprometernos a establecer relaciones a
partir de la empatía pero esta empatía
que va más allá de suponer cómo se
sentiría caminar en los zapatos del otro
o de la otra porque muchas veces
tratamos de adivinar o vamos según
nosotros siendo empáticos pero más como
un ejercicio de adivinación o de yo
supongo que en esa situación como yo me
sentí o me sentido entonces seguramente
así se siente él o ella pero la realidad
es que la experiencia de vida del otro y
de la otra es totalmente distinta a la
mía practicar la empatía pero más como
un acto de investigación a partir de
escuchar con atención de escuchar con la
intención de entender cómo es la
experiencia del otro de la otra a partir
de hacer preguntas a partir de observar
y con esa información tratar de
acercarme a entender mejor cómo es la
experiencia del otro de la otra y
finalmente una tercera acción que te
invito a hacer es a crear más espacios
de co-creación
esto implica soltar un poco esta idea de
que el líder es el que tiene que tener
todas las soluciones el que tiene que
definir las estrategias y repartir el
trabajo es reconocer que en un contexto
como éste hay gran riqueza de abrir
espacios para que juntos y juntos
podamos generar soluciones podamos
apalancar nos de la inteligencia
colectiva y ser creativos juntos esto es
algo que hicimos muchísimo desde que
empezó la pandemia muchos de nuestros
clientes como todos seguramente nos
enfrentamos a un montón de retos
inesperados y entonces creamos estos
espacios que les llamamos sesiones de
ideación donde básicamente lo que
hacíamos era generar un montón de ideas
para resolver un reto o un problema en
específico y una de las condiciones de
estas sesiones era asegurarnos que en
esas mesas de generación de ideas
hubiera diversidad diferentes niveles
dentro de la organización o diferentes
actores o personas relación nada con esa
problemática o ese reto que queríamos
resolver y sin duda generamos montones
de ideas en sesiones de no más de dos
horas encontrábamos hasta más de 100
alternativas de solución a un reto
específico pero creo que una de las
mayores riquezas que encontramos es lo
que escuchábamos al final de estas
sesiones constantemente personas
compartían que finalmente se habían dado
cuenta que su aportación era muy valioso
para el equipo hubo gente que comentó
cosas como hoy me di cuenta que puedo
ser creativo que tengo buenas ideas y
que es importante que las compartan
imagínense cuánto potencial cuánta
creatividad estamos desperdiciando por
no crear más espacios como éste sin duda
comprometernos con impulsar la
diversidad y la inclusión es una gran
oportunidad de robustecer nuestros
equipos de generar mejores resultados
mayores innovaciones de impulsar
organizaciones que sean más competitivas
pero también es una gran oportunidad
romper con estas dinámicas de exclusión
de discriminación que constantemente
encontramos en nuestras comunidades y en
nuestra sociedad hoy me doy cuenta que
gran parte del trabajo que realizó está
enfocado en facilitar estos espacios
para qué
cada vez menos personas tengan que vivir
o experimentar lo que yo viví hace seis
años con mi jefe y estoy convencida de
que si nos comprometemos a abrazar eso
que nos hace diferentes podemos generar
y construir mejores espacios de trabajo
pero sobre todo mejores realidades para
vivir muchísimas gracias
[Música]